here are seven developments in AI that
you might have missed this week from
chatgpt avatars to open source models on
an iPhone an alpha Dev to Zuckerberg's
projections of super intelligence but
first something a little unconventional
with a modicum of wackiness embodied VR
chess best robot on my left is being
controlled by a human in a suit over
there and this robot on my right is
being controlled by a human over there
they both have feedback gloves they have
VR headsets and they're seeing
everything that the robot sees now
specifically today we're looking at
avatars robot avatars to be precise they
can play chess but they can do much more
they can perform maintenance rescue
operations and do anything that a human
do with its hands and eyes could this be
the future of sports and things like MMA
where you fight using robotic embodied
avatars but for something a little less
intense we have this robot Chef who
learned by watching videos
foreign
[Music]
it does make me wonder how long before
we see something like this at a
McDonald's near you but now it's time to
talk about something that is already
available which is the hey gen plugin in
chat GPT it allows you to fairly quickly
create an avatar of the text produced by
Chachi BT and I immediately thought of
one use case that I think could take off
in the near future by combining the
Wolfram plugin with hey gen I asked
chatgpt to solve this problem and then
output an explainer video using an
avatar a quick tip here is to tell
Chachi PT the plugins that you wanted to
use otherwise it's kind of reluctant to
do so as you can see chatty PT using
Wolfram was able to get the question
right but for some people just reading
this text won't quite cut it so check
this out the retail price of a certain
kettlebell is seventy dollars
this price represents a 25 profit over
the wholesale cost
to find the profit per kettlebell sold
at retail price we first need to find
the wholesale cost
we know that seventy dollars is one
hundred and twenty five percent of the
wholesale cost
next we have Runway Gen 2 which I think
gives us a glimpse of what the future of
text the video will be like
a long long time ago at lady
winterbottom's lovely tea party which is
in the smoking ruins and Ashes of New
York City a fierce women ain't playing
no games and is out to kick some butts
against the unimaginable brutal
merciless and scary Blobby boy of the
delightful Grand Budapest Hotel hi and
everything seems doomed and lost until
some man arises the true hero and great
Mastermind behind all of this
now of course that's not perfect and as
you can see from my brief attempt here
there is lots to work on but just
remember where mid-journey was a year
ago to help you imagine where Runway
will be in a year's time and speaking of
a year's time if AI generated fake
images are already being used
politically imagine how they're going to
be used or videos in a year's time but
now it's time for the paper that I had
to read two or three times to grasp and
it will be of interest to anyone who is
following developments in open source
models I'm going to try to skip the
jargon as much as possible and just give
you the most interesting details
essentially they found a way to compress
large language models like Llama Or
Falcon across model scales and even
though other people had done this they
were able to achieve it in a near
lossless way this has at least two
significant implications one that bigger
models can be used on smaller devices
even as small as an iPhone and second
the inference speed gets speeded up as
you can see by 15 to 20 percent in
translation that means the output from
the language model comes out more
quickly so the best of my understanding
the way they did this is that they
identified an isolated outlier weights
in Translation that's the parts of the
model that are most significant to its
performance they stored those with more
bits that is to say with higher
Precision while compressing all other
weights to three to four bits that
reduces the amount of Ram or memory
required to operate the model there were
existing methods of achieving this
shrinking or quantization like round to
nearest or gptq but they ended up with
more errors and generally less accuracy
in text generation as we'll see in a
moment spqr did best across the model
scales to cut a long story short they
envisage models like Llama Or indeed
Orca which I just did a video on
existing on devices such as an iPhone
14. if you haven't watched my last video
on the Orca model do check it out
because it shows that in some tests that
13 billion parameter model is
competitive with chat gbt or GPT 3.5 so
imagining that on my phone which has 12
gigs of RAM is quite something here are
a few examples comparing the original
models with the outputs using spqr and
the older form of quantization and when
you notice how similar the outputs are
from spqr to the original model just
remember that it's about four times
smaller in size and yes they did compare
llama and Falcon at 40 billion
parameters across a range of tests using
spqr remember that this is the base
llama model accidentally leaked by meta
not an enhanced version like Orca and
you can see the results for llama and
Falcon are comparable and here's what
they say at the end spqr might have a
wide reaching effect on how large
language models are used by the general
population to complete useful tasks but
they admit that llms are inherently a
dual use technology that can bring both
significant benefits and serious harm
and it is interesting the waiver that
they give however we believe that the
marginal impact of spqr will be positive
or neutral in other words our algorithm
does not create models with new
capabilities and risks it only makes
existing models more accessible speaking
of accessible it was of course meta that
originally leaked llama and they are not
only working on a rival to Twitter
apparently called project 92 but also on
bringing in AI assistance to things like
WhatsApp and Instagram but Mark
Zuckerberg the head of meta who does
seem to be rather influenced by Jan
lacun's thinking does have some
questions about autonomous AI my own
view is that
where we really need to be careful is on
the development of autonomy and how we
think about that because it's actually
the case that relatively simple and
unintelligent things that have runaway
autonomy and just spread themselves or
you know it's like we have a word for
that it's a virus could be simple
computer code that is not particularly
intelligent but just spreads itself and
does a lot of harm a lot of wood I think
we need to develop when people talk
about safety and responsibility is
really the governance on the autonomy
that can be given to systems it does
seem to me though that any model release
will be fairly quickly made autonomous
look at the just two-week Gap the
release of GT4 and the release of Auto
GPT so anyone releasing a model needs to
assume that it's going to be made to be
autonomous fairly quickly next
Zuckerberg talked about super
intelligence and compared it to a
corporation you still didn't answer the
question of what year we're going to
have super intelligence I'd like to hold
you to there now I'm just kidding but is
there something you could say about the
timeline
as you think about the development of
AGI super intelligence systems
sure so I I still don't think I have any
particular Insight on when like a
singular AI system that is a general
intelligence will get created but I
think the one thing that most people in
the discourse that I've seen about this
haven't really grappled with is that we
do seem to have organiz organizations
and you know structures in the world
that exhibit greater than human
intelligence already so you know one
example is a you know a company but I I
certainly hope that you know meta with
tens of thousands of people make smarter
decisions than one person but I think
that would be pretty bad if it didn't I
think he's underestimating a super
intelligence which would be far faster
and more impressive I believe than any
company here's one quick example from
deepmind where their Alpha Dev system
sped up sorting small sequences by 70
because operations like this are
performed trillions of times a day this
made headlines but then I saw this
apparently Gypsy Ford discovered the
same trick as our confidev and the
author sarcastically asks can I publish
this on nature and to be honest when you
see the prompts that he used it strikes
me that he was using GPT 3.5 the
original Chachi BT in green not gpt4
anyway back to Super intelligence and
science at digital speed when you hear
the following anecdote from demisasabis
you might question the analogy between a
corporation and a super intelligence
Alpha fold is a sort of Science of
digital speed in two ways one is that it
can fold the proteins in you know
milliseconds instead of taking years of
experimental work right so 200 million
proteins you times that by PhD time of
five years that's like a billion years
of PhD time right by some measure that
has been done in in a year billions of
years of PhD time in the course of a
single year of computation honestly AI
is going to accelerate absolutely
everything and it's not going to be like
anything we have seen before thank you
so much for watching and have a
wonderful day